this is super exciting on the phone with
me my first phone er 480 Canada pride is
none other than skinny legend herself
Trixie Mattel hi Trixie hi how you doing
today I'm good just waking up here 8 in
the morning
I'm just getting older and see now I'm
one of those people who wakes up early
every day well big news coming to TV and
streaming platform Oh TV go there will
be 4 new live stand-up comedy specials
from your favorite drag queens of course
including yourself on Thursday September
26th at 10:00 p.m. fans will be able to
watch Trixie Mattel skinny legend how
exciting is that that's already out her
sister marie-therese tricks well there
you go
breaking news well the turnaround is
magical I mean I literally just approved
the laughs at it I had I had to watch it
like you know I had to watch it like 4
different times just to like tweak and
you know like certain little jokes I
wanted them to keep and then certain
little jokes I wasn't so crazy about
it's just trying to get it perfect it's
funny there's definitely some material
that is quite racy I think that's not
gonna be shocking to many people but are
you a bit of a perfectionist when you're
putting something out oh yeah I mean and
I'm a perfectionist when I'm putting it
together on the other hand I know that
you sort of just have to like do it and
let go of it because honestly I could I
could sit there amongst that special
over and over again and find you think I
know new things but like I want to
change or I wish I could do over like a
hair sticking on the head or oh you know
but really make peace with it well I'm
sure the audience will be laughing what
can they expect when they tune into
Trixie Mattel skinny legend uh no TV on
September 26 well I do things the way
only I can do it which is you know right
up to the line you were and then you
know right over the line sometimes yeah
and of course I'm playing my guitar you
know there's a lot of music in the show
there's some great opening numbers that
are super silly and stupid and but then
of course it's perfect hair flip it down
perfect makeup when I was making this
for our TV I tried to think of the
channel surfer I'm like
what if what will the channel surfer
think if they saw me in there or who I
was I'm so happy to see so many of you I
love you I love you I trust you trust
fall okay that'll be a pretty strong way
to start the show though wouldn't it I
might do it could you tell I'm kind of
an insecure performer most people call
that a stage dive I'm like it's the
three other Queens who have comedy
specials airing on O TV and o TV go
include Bob the drag queen Alaska and
your BFF Katya Katya was actually just
here on et Canada pride a month ago
where she said some nice things about
you she said that you are very caring so
I want you to tell me something about
Katya that people may not know oh god
what do people not know the thing is
because of our youtube series this is
funny place thanks a hundred five
episodes now yeah I will say she doesn't
act like it but she loves drag she loves
dressing up yeah she loves you would
never know it cuz usually she's just
trying to count the seconds till the
next book break yeah but like she loves
dressing up also whenever you think she
looks crazy just know that every part of
that outfit she thought about and put
together she's really never filling
things on she really purposefully tries
to look like a frag about yeah and
that's part of her charm she also
mentioned you have a very chunky ass so
I have to tell you that I was bouncing
around my own chunky ass in the office
this morning listening to you teaming up
with todrick Hall on chapstick that is
such a fire song I don't even own this
type of music except your music
[Music]
I just could not believe how great you
two are together on that track how much
fun did you have putting that together
with him oh my god are you kidding me
what's funny is like in any of every
interviewer where I talk about folk
music is amazing it's not those stupid
club tracks yeah part of it because I'm
a drag queen has no natural gifts and
like rapper club music so I'll just take
a little jello who believe me like when
I look good big really good like we're
talking like a lobster this is my hair
yeah Bob her Spurs like the good dragon
yeah I just don't have like an
inclination to that so when I almost
call them Shadrach chapstick todrick
asked me to do that I was like he sent
me the demo and he is so legit he lists
that he likes any little clip on his
phone of him tapping on the table and
rapping to himself oh wow even from that
little double I was like I'm obsessed
with this song he was like good cuz I
wrote it for you and I have to tell you
too I come from a country music
background so I really love what you're
doing with the country and folk vibes I
worked at CMT Canada for about 10 years
so having a drag queen come out and
represent a genre like country music
that isn't always represented in that
kind of way is just incredible um fans
are waiting for album number three
yellow cloud is out of course
[Music]
give me a little tea on album number
three well either late this year early
next year I mean independent artist you
know I don't have like important people
in suits breathing down my neck
I go I go with the wind you know so I'm
reading it now and I don't know people
can tell but I'm less obsessed with
chronology yeah and so like you know my
first record it's kind of like 50s radio
country you know I'm on the front like
with like stacks of hay it's very like
country times yeah and then I said you
know the one stone there's a little like
early sixties folk revival yeah and then
my new album it's gonna be a little more
like later 60 it's gonna have more of a
post Beatles invasion sort of like radio
radio folk pop sound so everything will
be a little more plugged in and fuzzy
and hand clappy and sweet I'm also a lot
happier
so my music is a little less bum bum
doubt it's just me more sweet like
little love songs and stuff I love
hearing that and one thing actually
suggested something they said can you
please ask Trixie if she can put out a
remastered version of hello goodbye on
her third studio album is that a
possibility because a lot of fans liked
that suite so that seems to be a song
that they want remastered and put out
there would you ever consider doing that
what yeah I mean that song was used in
in my documentary she's Mattel moving
parts there's a shot of me in a hotel by
myself just playing my guitar I wrote it
I was like 19 yeah and the filmmakers
were like oh my god we we want to use
that so fine who wrote it could be
publishing or whatever and I was like
well I wrote that and then they were
like oh my god everybody's watching the
movie they all asked what what song that
is they loved it so we may or may not
have recently we recorded at least an
acoustic version of it oh okay so fans
may get that somewhat soon yes and
you're the first people to hear about it
hooray I love some tea here on a tea
Canada pride well finally I could talk
to you forever
I really hope you're able to come to
Toronto sometime and come in studio with
me and hang out on a tea Canada pride
because that will be super fun I'm sure
we could shoot the boat
love that bring my guitar and we could
play some music oh my gosh that sounds
like such a plan but again I am so
excited for people to see Trixie Mattel
skinny legend on Oh TV and Oh TV go
because it is something you do not want
to miss it's a complete dream of mine my
earliest memories are watching you know
Ellen you're in now or like you know
Cathy business Bravo special so it's
really really a gag there's also a
feature-length documentary the Queen's
airing on O TV and available on Oh TV go
on Friday September 13th at 10:00 p.m.
that features jinkx monsoon Alaska Katya
and Sharon Needles cameras followed them
behind the scenes for two years you're
getting kind of behind the scenes access
how cool is that I'm so excited to watch
it myself
and thanks for hanging and chatting with
me of course but all right bye